and now it's time for the Bjork Show
welcome to tonight's guests baloney
sandwich and from his movie dead men to
live Edward Northman so let's get on
with the show we're going to have a
wonderful show for you today but wait a
minute do you hear that
it's our friend mr. pony what's on your
mind butterfly butterfly butterfly
butterfly
wasn't that fun and now I'd like to
welcome our first guest
he's an Academy Award nominee here to
talk about his new film Deadman tumbler
please welcome Edward Norman first of
all let me just say I am a huge fan of
your work I mean that the music is so
surreal and inspiring I mean is jazz I
absolutely love it
oh thank you mr. Norman I'm a big fan of
your movies did you know I was in a
movie once
oh yeah dancer in the dark yeah I heard
that wasn't very good
oh not that you know I haven't made a
bad film maybe I'm sure I have somewhere
I did okay I can't think of any right
now but you know I mean I bet - smooth -
you see that nose as a horrible film
maybe I never saw it but I hear was
terrible how how how did you do that
um is there any chance we can talk about
my hippie okay well it's about a guy who
used to be a cop until he was tragically
shot in the hip
yeah him and he's debating whether or
not he should still stay on the force I
have a clip
very good you want to see it no okay
because we haven't talked our first
guest yet baloney sandwich Oh mr. Norman
say the Lord's the sandwich I'm very
calm can't we just come to the club
there is no Clint let's go to the
sandwich say hello hello
sandwiches can't talk mr. Sherman
well uh yes actually I do her name is
Salma Hayek perhaps you've heard of her
she's a wonderful actress and really
knows just what she's doing it has her
brain together and everything it's just
beautiful beautiful woman as well we
actually worked together on the movie
called our freedom which is a fantastic
movie I suggest you look it up I Jesus
how are you doing that did you say it's
your girlfriend's birthday
I I don't recall saying that Oh God
because I love birthdays let's sing okay
happy birthday to you well I gotta say
it's been a slice of ya I don't know
what but it's certainly been a slice has
been an experience if you're ever in the
neighborhood okay where did you go
look I don't have time for this I get to
humor Jay Leno in an hour okay I'm
sticking this you're weird
your show is weird your freaky ass music
is weird I'm getting the hell out of
here I don't like you well that's all
the time we have for today please join
me next time where I'll be dressed as a
cauliflower